the discussion around the new song and
video from lil nazex which
features the rapper sliding down to hell
on a stripper pole and
giving a lap dance to satan has mostly
focused on the allegedly shocking nature
of the content but there's nothing new
about a musical artist i use that term
loosely resorting to
satanic imagery in order to generate
publicity and controversy
guys like marilyn manson rob zombie you
know they were doing in the 90s
metal bands were doing it before them
ozzy osbourne was decapitating bats with
his teeth on stage two decades before
lil nazex was even born
the fact that all of this stuff has been
done before doesn't make it any less
abhorrent
but it does make it banal and
uninteresting
we have we have reason to object to this
sort of material but no reason to be
shocked by it
is the point we also miss the point
if we're focused only on the content
itself as if it exists in a vacuum
if if lil na's x is blazing any new
trails
it's only because he's the first person
i think
to go this route less than a year after
performing with elmo
on sesame street
[Music]
oh
[Music]
now there he is on sesame street with
with his uh with his first hit
old town road a song so bad that it
makes you long for the traditional
country stylings of you know luke bryan
lil nazex gained a large audience of
very young children
and this was no accident the rapper and
his handlers
made a decision to cultivate this fan
base with appearances on
children's television shows like you
just saw performances at elementary
schools
they even released a children's book now
in an apparent an appearance on the view
less than three months ago
he explicitly attributed his success to
children let's listen to that
well you know uh with the success of old
town road
you know majority of that success i
would like a tribute to
kids uh and they like they love this
song so much
and i this idea that children's book was
bought brought to me and i was like
this makes perfect sense now around the
same time a headline
on npr's uh website also from
a few months ago reports quote lil nazex
says children
are his core audience right now and
that's okay
well turns out it's really not okay
while responding to the backlash on
twitter this week
the artist said that he um he quote had
nine months to plan this rollout and
brag that quote
y'all are not gonna win talking about
his critics like me
now while while he deserves praise for
composing a mostly coherent tweet there
with correct punctuation a bar that he
doesn't often seem to reach
what this post really confirms is that
he and his record label were
very intentionally building his
kindergarten fan base
while also planning at the same time
this move into demonic and pornographic
territory
marilyn manson you know was wasn't doing
sing-alongs with elmo or appearing on
the view to talk about his children's
book three months before
antichrist superstar came out the record
industry along with hollywood
has always had designs on your children
we know that what makes this
notable right now is how incredibly
blatant it is
and how young their targets are
granted you know it's it's not the fault
of will nazax or his record label
columbia records by the way if you
allowed your five-year-old to listen to
his music on repeat
that doesn't get them off the hook the
fact that you shouldn't have allowed
them to prey on your kids
doesn't provide them a moral
justification for doing so
still it's worth noting uh the lyrics to
the song
that elementary schools invited lil nos
x to come perform
here's part of the second verse it says
riding on a tractor
lean all in my bladder cheated on my
baby you can go and ask her my life is a
movie
bull riding in boobies now not only is
this
the most aggressively stupid assemblage
of words that the english language has
ever been forced to endure
is also not exactly family friendly
i mean why were you letting your kids
sing this
he is after all singing about driving
his tractor while hopped up on cough
syrup and alcohol
after cheating on his significant other
if you let your third grader
go around singing the line my life is a
movie bull riding in boobies
a significant amount of the blame has to
fall at your own feet
but this again does not excuse
the music industry predators who are
trying to remake your children
in their own image as brain dead
degenerates
but it it does provide a valuable
learning opportunity
the lesson is that the entertainment
industry
with rare exception is not on your side
it has its own notions about what sort
of person your child should be what
values he should hold
what ideas he should have how he should
speak what he should what is
what he should wear everything who he
should hang out with
how he should conduct himself and not
only has these plans for your kid
but it also possesses perhaps the most
powerful mechanism for enacting them
art you know even bad art
moves people in ways that no other
medium can
which is why by the way it's also very
stupid when you hear even conservatives
who will look at something like this
and they'll say well it's just a song
what's the big deal don't make a big
deal out of it
it's just a song oh yeah that's right
it's it's only art it's only the number
one thing that moves and motivates
people that's all it is
it's it's it's it's it's something that
perhaps like nothing else can
can mold you know your your heart and
your mind
that's it no big deal
you morons now it's it's likely that
millions of children who are
subscribed to the little not little
nasdaq's youtube channel
um and allowed by foolish parents to use
youtube without supervision
it's likely that millions of them were
exposed to his satan lap dance video
over the weekend
which was put out without warning of
course no attempt made by
uh the rapper himself or the record
label
to warn anybody or say hey you know
we're we're making a move now into adult
territory
uh don't let your kid watch this if
they're subscribed to our youtube
channel probably unsubscribe
none of that of course youtube itself
puts parental filters on all kinds of
videos especially videos
that contain conservative political
opinions
but they didn't put one on the video
with the guy singing about performing
fellatio on another man while gyrating
on the devil's lap
now this doesn't mean when you think
about all these kids exposed to this
over the weekend
um this doesn't mean that all all of
them are going to run off and join
the satanic temple maybe some of them
will but it does mean
that they will be exposed and were
exposed
to depraved ideas and images that they
don't
understand and can't mentally filter
or process all they're going to know
is that the message is coming from their
favorite singer
the man who wrote that fun book and sang
that silly song on sesame street
and so it can't be that bad this is how
the grooming process works
and it's why you have to protect your
children from it
because nobody else will well i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the matt well
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content